the young people are fed up and took to
the streets of New York to say it's time
for adults not only to acknowledge
climate change but instead to do
something about it
you're only 17 years old why is it
important for you to be here today this
whole movement is youth-led we're the
ones who are going to be affected the
most by climate change because we have
the longest time ahead of us and we are
the ones who by traditional means don't
have much political power actions like
this show that we have a voice in our
futures here I've were in zero hour in
red lipstick it means that this is
really like zero hour like no more time
left to act on climate change because
people around the world already being
affected they are taking their message
straight to older people in positions of
power like at this climate strike in
Washington DC but in America New York is
the focal point on Thursday a giant
melting glacier was projected on the
side of the United Nations headquarters
as well as words scrolled down the side
demanding action on climate change world
leaders are gathering at the UN next
week for the annual General Assembly but
it was the noise on the streets Friday
and to make those world leaders take
notice
easily hundreds of thousands of people
demonstrating through the streets of New
York City right now mostly young people
this is happening in over a thousand
different cities throughout the United
States but not only here globally as
well across the Pacific Islands many of
which are already experiencing the
impact of rising sea levels a pledge to
fight climate change there are protests
in Australia where several hundred
thousand people skipped school college
or work to take part and in India more
demonstrations and a groundswell of
global angst and passion for action also
seen in South Africa
all told demonstrations and more than a
hundred and fifty countries even
experienced activists say they are
learning from the youth I have to say
they can communicate much better than
many of us they have creativity
innovation and the way they have
energized the numbers of young people
that are coming every country of v-net
in the last six months I've been so
inspired they're now saying it's no
longer a matter of trying to bring
attention to climate change but rather
what to do about it
Gabriel Sandow al Jazeera New York